first descents are basically modern
exploration
when you're climbing a piece of rock
that no human has ever touched you
literally step into the unknown
[Music]
we're on an expedition into the glorious
heart of south america
oh look right there dr bruce means is
basically on a one-man mission
to look for new species in this unique
place in the world that scientists
haven't really explored but there's one
final place he has never been able to
get to to complete his work
high on the tapue cliff walls themselves
so i called alex arnold good to see you
the single boldest climber in the world
the trip like this is something that
i've always wanted to do in my life but
i think it'll be really scary
it's going to be a wild adventure
tapu is a sort of islands in the sky
it's such an extreme place to get to i
was looking at the approach and thinking
how in the world are we going to get
bruce to the top
thankfully you brought a climber with
you
this trip could be his magnum opus the
magnificence of nature
but the terrain is getting steeper and
more complicated
this looks dangerous
i'm all right
if we push on we're risking your life
it's all news here
this is freaking crazy
wow
only our feet have been here that i'm
aware of
you